- Does everyone in your
school smoke those Juuls?
- You know, it was a
big thing at my school.
My school's a pretty, like
rebellious school in that sense;
there was a lot of people that got,
like, suspended and expelled
for Juuling in the bathroom
- Dang
Juuling, is that what they call it?
- [Milo and Alexis] Juuling.
- Ooo, Juuling; okay.
- Yeah, but yeah, I mean, it's a problem.
I mean, it's a problem at every school;
it's not just my school
- Yeah
- You know what I mean?
But, it's a huge, huge epidemic
- Juuling in the bathroom for me
was singing Juul with my
friends in the bathroom.
♪ You were meant for me! ♪
We would just like all
- (laughs) That's Juuling;
Hey you wanna meet
(laughs)
after school at a Juul in the bathroom?
- We got in trouble for it so much!
(Pop-punk theme tune)
- Yeah, Milo you became a man
on one of your dances; everyone knows it,
everyone reacted to it.
- [Milo] Yep.
- And, we're not gonna talk about it
until you t-
- Turn 18
- March, yeah.
- OK, I can't wait to hear about it
- I wanna know what it is!
- Yeah, me too; I don't know what it is!
- OK, here's the thing;
Dancing With the Stars is,
that's why there's
separate show for children
because you can't put children
into these sexy dances.
It feels weird to watch
because men on the show,
regardless of who they
are, like, get sexy.
Women, regardless of who they are
get sexier than you've ever seen them.
And it's just like a weird,
and Milo had some dances that were sexy.
- Yeah
- I'm not gonna lie
- Did something really dirty happen?
- If the ladies are listening,
here are the dances that
I would direct them to:
We've got
- His finale dance.
- His finale dance one hundred percent!
- One hundred thousand percent.
- I've watched it
- [Alexis and Nikki] So many times
- The little drip sounds
- The contemporary
- Bloop!
- Asylum?
- Ohh.
- That one, oof, that was such a good one.
- The one from the Halloween episode
They do a
- Halloween episode, so good.
- I mean, it is one of the best dances.
- Honestly one of the best dances
- [Nikki] He like plays
one of the mental patients.
- I've seen on the show
- Shut up!
- The problem with that dance,
- [Milo] Tell me the problem
- So the whole theme of that dance is
- It's like Britney Spears
- [Milo and Nikki] Toxic
- But it's to this, like,
it's done almost acoustically
It's broken down.
- It's really creepy
- And it's creepy! Yeah, it's like
(Huming "Toxic" riff)
- But it's also sexy.
- Beautiful, yes;
- [Alexis] Yeah.
- It is sexy, but that's
the problem I had with it.
'Cause Witney's playing his nurse,
and I'm like there's something going on
between this patient
- [Alexis] Oh yes!
- And the nurse, and where's the protocol?
- There's a story behind it.
- [Nikki] I mean I wanna
go to HR about this.
- Yes, well it was kind of like
when we were coming up with the dance
we were really stuck on the story,
and we were like-
- Yeah, why is this nurse
taking advantage of her patient!?
- At first we were like
she's a real nurse.
and she falls in love with me.
- Yeah
- And then we were like
nah, how 'bout I fall in love with her.
And then were were like, wait,
what if she's not even like a real nurse?
- Oh
- So what we ended up
tryin' to do was that
she's like a figment of my imagination,
but it didn't really
end up looking that way.
It just kind of looked like
- She was a naughty nurse.
- This insane asylum dude
- [Nikki] (laughs)
- With this nurse that had, like, a thing.
- That dance is so good,
so watch the asylum dance,
and then, yeah, what was the one,
the weekend one?
- The, was it the Argentine Tango
where you did that?
- Yeah, that one didn't really,
like, do as well though.
Like, that one doesn't have
as many views on YouTube.
- Okay, just stick to the other two then.
- Okay, but I thought that
one was gonna be really good.
That one I feel like is by far my most
underrated dance.
- But to be honest with you,
people on YouTube, all those people;
they want wow factor
- Yeah
- And, like, they don't
like just good technique.
- They don't understand, like you get it
- They don't understand,
they don't care
- Yes!
- So it's like, it could be
an amazing Argentine Tango,
but all they see is like, your
feet flippin' back and forth.
They wanna see you do cartwheels
and jump in water, and like,
- [Milo] Yeah.
- Yes, that's what I wanna see.
I don't care
- [Alexis] Yeah, exactly
- About technique!
(Cacophony of agreement)
- You don't care about technique, right!
- That's what I told
Witney all the time too.
I was like, I need to
back-flip off this table.
We need to get water.
- And it happened!
- Yeah, exactly
- Yeah, yeah
That's the thing about that show
is you're constantly trying to manage
being good for the judges
so you get those scores, and
being technically perfect.
But also trying to appeal
- Exactly!
- To voters and be entertaining
- That is the hardest thing about it.
- And you're juggling
those two, and, I mean,
so much of the show is not about dancing
it's about your packages
- So much!
- I'd say even more;
- I would say the packages
are more important.
- More about you as a
person than your dancing.
- Yeah, so the packages are the things,
the videos that run before the dance
that kind of, like,
establish the relationship
between the couple, that's
either brewing or yeah
I mean you, you were in so many,
- (laughs) Exposed!
- Hashtag X-posed!
- A lof of people don't know
Alexis Ren
- [Alexis] Jesus Christ
was with Alan Bernsten
(Alexis clears her throat)
- Andrew, let me just like
tell you what, okay so,
we go into the show,
and before it even begins everyone's like
Alan's like in love with Alexis
- Well, duh!
- He has a huge crush on her,
it's like, yeah duh, exactly.
- Like, duh
- [Nikki] Everyone does!
- Wait, why is it a duh?
- Look at Alexis' face right now!
- She's the most unattractive person
I've ever seen in my life
- Thank you for saying that!
- You mean this four you put me next to
for the whole fuckin' radio show?
(general laughter)
- Like I give a shit!
- [Nikki] Alexis hasn't been
a four since she was four.
- I'm more attracted to the dude!
- I know, I would agree
with you on that one.
- Yeah, this guy's more
of a fuckin' babe than this dump!
- Oh my god!
(laughing)
- Thank you so much.
- Come on.
Somebody's gotta take everyone down
- Yeah, someone.
- OK, go ahead, I get
it, she's very attractive
somebody said
- Keep changing the subject
I like this
Somebody said she's very attractive,
and then they got a crush on her, right?
- Yes, exactly so you can imagine
a world in which someone would
have a crush on her, right?
I know its kind of a stretch
- Its hard to imagine but it happens
- I mean, not for someone
like me, 'cause, like I
said she's very, very ugly.
- Yeah, you're into looks
- I'm not into looks at all!
- No, you are into looks
- I am into looks
oh, yeah, that's what it is right;
that's why I'm not attracted
- And you know that she's
just not bringin' it
on that front
(laughing)
- Yeah no, not at all;
not even a little bit.
And I am a supermodel
- Another thing about Alexis Ren,
I was completely
intimidated to meet her.
When I first found out
she was on the show,
I was like God dammit.
Like, I was watching her
looking at her Instagram
and being like I can't
have this thing around me.
(Alexis grunts uncomfortably)
Prancin' around with that
waist, it's just like
- That waist!
- That waist!? Oh my god!
- Waist!? (laughs)
- Those little hips!
- [Nikki] I was so nervous
about her, but her waist
is like really annoying.
(Alexis laughs)
- Why?
- 'Cause it's so small
- Yeah, it's tiny?
- And it's like Disney Princess small
where it looks like.
'Cause sometimes they'll break down
Disney Princesses or barbies
- [Alexis] (mumbling) Oh
my God, so uncomfortable!!
- And they go: To achieve this,
you would have to not have
ribs, and it's impossible.
- Oh, people think I took my ribs out;
I was like no, I actually
just fractured them.
- Honestly, people have asked me about it.
- That's another thing that
Dancing With the Stars never brought up;
- She fractured two ribs!
- That entire time,
I was two ribs, two different weeks.
They didn't say shit.
I was like, you guys, this like,
I had to take a pain shot in my ass
every single show day.
- Yeah.
- Yeah
- Like, we're gonna stick
with the relationship story.
- There was, Nikki, there
were some interviews
that, like, I fully looked
like I was on some shit.
- Because you were!
- 'Cause you were on some shit!
- (laughs) I was!
- They're not scared to put,
and Dancing With the
Stars isn't hiding this;
I mean sometimes it feels like they,
'cause I got injured too,
and it was
constantly like do I tell them about it,
do I put it out on camera?
- I made a huge deal out
of the smallest injury.
- Don't do it, don't put it out there
that you're injured,
and I'd be like wait, but I am,
and I need people to know,
I need the producers to
understand how injured I am.
I need a shot in my back
- [Alexis] Yeah
- Or I can't do this
- And, but, you're also
trying to not seem injured
so that they keep you on.
Like, it's a mindfuck
- Right, that's the thing
- It's hard.
- I got like barely injured;
like I pulled my groin
tryin' to do something
in like the Jive or something.
And I was trying to like tell everyone
I need help, I need to
use the physical trainer
and all that, but I
also didn't want to like
make it a thing on the show
- Yeah
- Because that's scary, like it's scary.
- If you're listening,
Dancing With the Stars,
there needs to be a system in place
in which you can honestly talk to someone
who it's not gonna affect your
- Position on the show?
- Yeah, the EPs aren't gonna find out,
but like you need to
be able to tell someone
when you're injured and not
have it backfire against you.
Because that is the fear
that you kind of lived with
on the show
- Yeah, you didn't
want a it to be a pity party
- [Nikki] No
- Exactly
I didn't, I told Alan I was
like I don't wanna tell anyone.
Like, I don't, I wanna keep this like
- [Nikki] Sighs
- And he was like no
you should, you should tell people.
Like, that's pretty serious.
- [Nikki] Yeah
- He was like, if you
pulled something cool,
but you fractured a rib.
- Yep.
- It really does make sense now.
- This is how NFL athletes feel
- Dude, it is
- Think about how,
- It is worse
- I know
Think about how, they have
to get cortisone shots
- They're like I have brain damage;
and like you're fine, get back out there.
- Oh yeah you're right I mean
it's the same thing just go out and dance.
- I like how when you were like
"if Dancing With the Stars is listening"
the room full of executives
listening to this right now,
and they're like, we won't!
We won't change for Nikki, no.
- No, they're not, I mean
no one changes anything,
it's a system that works.
- That's how they make the most money.
- [Nikki] Clearly it works
- They wanna keep you scared,
obviously; that's good.
'Cause if you're under
their thumb a little bit,
then you're gonna have to
perform and feel that way.
- When did it set in for you guys
that you're like, oh wait
I'm on a reality show.
Hold on a second.
- Not even on the show;
it was almost until someone recognized me
that I was like oh yeah,
you're watching this
like outside of the studio.
Like, I'm on your TV.
- You're in this little bubble
that you don't realize.
- Yeah exactly.
- Right, what I mean by that more is like
you're being manipulated
to look a certain way on TV
because it's a reality, it's not a
- [Milo] Yes
- [Alexis] Yeah
- You don't have control is
essentially what I'm saying.
- 100%
- [Nikki] And I will say
- Feel like Alexis felt
that more than I did
- Yeah I mean it's different
for each person
- I felt like I,
I mean I, nothing really was that twisted
in my story if that makes sense, you know?
'Cause, they were keeping
the pretty innocent
story of like I'm the kid,
- [Nikki] Yeah
- In here just havin' a great time;
we're just tryin' to do a good job.
- And that's truly what I
saw behind the scenes too.
- Yeah, it really was
- It was really, like,
- Every time I walked into
your guys' like classes
you guys were doin' some joking, laughing
like, you know
- I've never laughed so hard.
- Milo (laughs) would like open the door
to look at me (laughs) and Alan,
- Then she'd be
- And I'd be like
I would look at him and be like
- On the floor
- "Help."
- With like tears like
swelling up in her eyes
- Why!? Why?
- Well, I'd like, Okay well:
The way Alan teaches, he's
- He's Russian
- He's Russian, so he has a
very like do or die mentality.
And, like, I don't react well to that.
Like, I'm more of like
be loving towards me,
and like lift me to the light
- I feel that too.
- Like, be kind, and I
will do my best for you.
And so it was that constant battle
of, like, don't be mean please.
- That's, I relate to that
- I like Russians 'cause they're mean.
- [Milo] They're intense
- They're honest
- They're like, Do it.
- They're very honest.
- (Russian accent) Don't be a pussy!
- Exactly!
- Do it!
- When I went on tour
and I was just with like
Lev and Val
- (accent) Don't be a bitch
- And all the Russians I've
never so like hard in my life.
Like I've never felt like I just
- Yeah, because they've gone through
way more than all of us!
- I know, they really
have gone through a lot.
- (Russian accent) You
don't like to do the dance?
I used to eat stones for breakfast.
- (laughs) That's true, I mean
I think Gleb was my partner,
it was a similar situation
where it was like,
and I remember, you know you have a call
with a producer before you
even agree to do the show.
And she's, and this woman we
all know, I love her, Dina.
- You have a call with her,
and she kind of talks
you into doing the show,
but like
- [Milo] Yeah, she's great.
- In a really sincere way
- [Milo] Yes
- [Alexis] She's so sweet.
- And she tells you what it's gonna be,
she's honest about it.
And I remember being,
her being like, now what
do you want in a partner?
'Cause she kind of is
like a matchmaker, right?
- [Milo] Yeah
- And I was like,
first I wanna find someone
super hot and single;
I'm like, well they didn't give me that.
I was like, I'd like to romance,
I would love a budding
romance on reality TV.
Like, I don't care, like gimme it!
- [Alexis] Yeah
- So they didn't do that
'cause they're like we don't
wanna see that out of you.
(Milo and Alexis giggle)
- We already have our
sights set on that one.
And I was like I want it, but, most of all
what I wanted was someone who would
'cause I was like this is
gonna be very hard for me;
I want someone who's emotionally available
and is going to believe
in me despite everything.
And it's just gonna be positive.
And there, she was like
I know just the person,
and I'm like you do? (laughs)
'Cause Russians don't have that in them.
- [Milo] Yeah
- [Alexis] No!
- To be everything' gonna be OK.
Gleb would click into that
and be like it's fine,
everything's gonna be fine,
and I go, you don't mean
it, you're lying right now.
And then he wouldn't be able to be,
he's like yeah yeah
I'm lying, it's not OK.
Like, you're not good.
It's like he would just reason with me.
So you had a lot of that with Alan.
- [Alexis] Yeah
- Where he was hard on you.
- Yeah
- 'Cause you're a very, you
wanted to keep it fun, right?
- Yeah, I mean, it is a dance show,
so that I had to keep reminding myself
because I got, you get swooped up into it
- Yeah
- Like, it gets very serious.
- It becomes the only thing
- [Nikki] Oh, yeah
- It's a little vortex.
- I mean, my listeners
have heard me talk about
when I got kicked out I like didn't know
how to like function
- [Milo] Talk? (laughs)
- In normal society; I'd be like,
(fake crying) I think my
salsa coulda been stronger!
And my friend's like, I have Lyme disease.
I'm like OK
(Milo and Alexis laughing)
- Yeah, we should probably
- [Milo And Nikki] Talk about that
- That's kinda impacting
everyone's life more
Yeah, I really; it's a bubble to be in.
The whole Kavanaugh trial happened
during Dancing With the Stars,
and I like didn't pay attention to it.
- I didn't know what was
going on in the outside world.
- I got out of the thing,
and I'm like I still don't believe women.
(laughing loudly)
It didn't get to me.
I missed so much news;
it was almost nice to
take a break from
- [Milo] It was!
- Anything else
- [Alexis] Yeah.
- To care about anything else,
but I love, what I saw out of you, Alexis,
and that's when I was like,
oh my God, she's fantastic.
Because we were friendly
throughout the show,
and I definitely saw a side of you
that I would never have
anticipated before meeting you;
I thought you were just
gonna be this model,
this vapid model that is
just hot and knows she's hot
and doesn't wanna talk to
anyone and wasn't friendly.
Like, you just project a
bunch of shit onto everyone
- [Alexis] Yeah
- And that's what I projected onto you;
it was immediately disproven
at Good Morning America
when I chatted you up
and gave you 2 seconds
to be, like, to talk to you
and then I was like, oh she's great.
But then I really was
sold on you the last show;
I went back for the finale,
and like I wasn't even competing;
I mean I was far from, I
was just there hangin' out.
And you had the same vibe as
me of like I'm just hangin'
you were not letting it get to you
in a way that was like you
weren't gonna enjoy it.
- Yeah
- [Nikki] And you were at the finals!
And everyone else in the finals took it
- [Milo] Including me.
- Was stressed
- [Milo] I was freaking out
- And like just in a mindset of
(panic voice) if I don't win,
like, what's gonna happen,
and you really, I don't know what kind of
placidity you achieved in that moment,
but you were so chill to be around.
And I was like, why are you so chill,
how did you do that.
- It was the shot; no, I'm kidding
(laughing loudly)
(pop punk music)
(Turntable slowdown)
(Sonar beep)